-Joe Biden has been elected
the 46th President
in the United States
in a historic and overwhelming
repudiation of Donald Trump
that ended with
Rudy Giuliani screaming
outside a landscaping company.
And now nearly
the entire Republican Party
is in lockstep behind Trump
as he tries to delegitimize
and steal the election.
For more on this, it's time for
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
Well, our long national
acid trip is almost over,
and now it's time
to pop a Klonopin
and let our designated
driver take us home.
On Saturday,
all the major networks
finally called the presidential
election for Joe Biden,
and I have to say,
even I'm surprised
at just how relieved I am
that we don't have to suffer
through another four years
of Donald Trump,
the single most annoying human
being on the face of the Earth.
Even if you put aside
everything else about him --
the racism, venality, cruelty,
corruption, mendacity,
vindictiveness,
and flagrant disregard
for any life
other than his own,
he is still just a world-
historically irritating man,
and the most irritating thing
about him
was my and and many people's
absolute round-the-clock
inability to look away.
For four years, it has been
genuinely necessary
to monitor the President
24 hours a day, like zoologists
staring at two endangered rhinos
hoping they'll have sex.
I mean, can you imagine living
through another four years
of having to see his sweaty,
overcooked ham of a face
on your television every day --
whining about toilets
not flushing
or windmills killing birds,
barking at reporters on his lawn
like a Long Island
mattress store owner
who insists on doing
his own commercials
and putting all his weird,
asymmetrical adult children
in them?
[ As Donald Trump ] "So come on
down to Oceanside Mattress
and use the promo code
'Shut Up And Lay Down.'"
[ Normal voice ] And thank God,
we won't have to
watch him dance
at his rallies anymore,
like the naked guy
in the gym locker room
using his a towel to dry
the back of his neck.
This point...
[ Laughs ]
...in addition to preserving
what's left of our democracy,
reversing four years
of malicious racism,
savagery, and criminal neglect,
getting rid of Trump is just
a quality-of-life issue,
like calling 311
about a jackhammer
outside your apartment.
And clearly, I'm not the only
one indulging myself
in the joy and catharsis
of seeing
this deeply wretched husk
of a man thrown out on his ass.
As the results came in
over the last few days --
culminating with
the official call
from the networks
on Saturday --
there were celebrations
across the country,
with people dancing
in the streets,
honking, and banging pots
in New York City,
flipping off Trump's
motorcade in D.C.,
dressing up as mailboxes
in Philadelphia,
and trolling Trump by blasting
what has become
his campaign's theme music --
the "YMCA" song.
-♪ It's fun to stay
at the YMCA ♪
♪ It's fun to stay at the ♪
-♪ YMCA! ♪
-It's just fantastic,
and I love they're doing it
right outside the White House.
It's like playing
"New York, New York"
outside of Fenway Park.
I like to imagine that while
this was happening,
there was a also a sad flotilla
of Trump's beautiful boaters
mournfully circling the waters
off Clearwater Beach
to a funeral-dirge version
of "YMCA."
"Why, God, why...
M-C-A."
Dancing crowds weren't
the only people overjoyed
by the fact that we'll soon be
rid of Donald Trump.
It was Joe Biden himself
who came bounding out
for his victory speech
like a journeyman reliever
jogging out from the bullpen
after finally getting called
up to the big leagues.
It's nice to get Quaid
from "The Rookie"
after four years of Quaid
from "Total Recall."
-[ Screaming ]
-I know in one case,
it's the actor's name,
and in the other,
it's the character's name,
but the joke is
for Andy Samberg,
and I'm pretty sure he's gonna
like it just fine.
Anyway, I think we can all admit
that when we were watching
Biden jog out,
we were silently hoping
he wouldn't fall.
Anytime a 77-year-old man
exerts himself like that,
it's a white-knuckle ride.
Biden's definitely
one of those grandpas
who insists on doing
everything himself.
"Grandpa, it's 5:00 in the
morning. Where are you going?"
"I'm gonna shovel the sidewalk
before my back pills wear off."
And then, Biden spoke
for the first time
as President-Elect, and I mean
this in the best possible way --
I remember very little of it.
Like, I think he said stuff
about healing our divides
or unifying the country --
or whatever.
Honestly, I'm just relieved
that a President-Elect
spoke to the nation
and I didn't immediately Google
"Canada how move to."
And then, Today, Biden announced
a task force of experts
who will guide him in dealing
with the coronavirus pandemic,
which, let's not forget,
is currently ravaging
the country uncontrolled,
with ICUs filling up
and hospitalizations
nearing record levels.
And yet, as the crisis was
continuing to spiral,
the current President was moping
around his private golf course,
like a Palm Beach dentist
after a messy divorce.
And that's also where Trump was
when the race was called
for Biden on Saturday,
which is just perfect.
Surprised he didn't
just stay out there.
[ Imitating Donald Trump ]
"Just leave me here.
I live with the geese now."
[ Normal voice ] I wonder if
his aides gave him the news
out on the course
or waited until he got back.
If I were them, I'd wait until
he doesn't have
a golf club in his hand.
Can you imagine the rage divots
he left behind?
It's probably why Rudy Giuliani
always looks like that.
He gave Trump
some bad news once,
and there's still a 9-iron
wedged up his ass.
So, clearly, Biden supporters
and sane people everywhere
got to enjoy a well-earned
national moment of catharsis
as the results came in.
Now, let's check in
on the other side
and see how they're
taking the news.
-President Trump
should not concede.
-It was stolen.
-The media is desperately trying
to get everyone to coronate
Joe Biden as the next president.
-I think he would
have to do a lot
to convince Republicans
that this is anything
except a left-wing power grab
financed by people
like George Soros.
I think that it is
a corrupt, stolen election.
-There is no Joe Biden.
The man you may remember
from the 1980s is gone.
He no longer exists.
What remains is
a projection of sorts,
a hologram designed
to mimic the behavior
of a non-threatening
political candidate.
These people seek
absolute sameness,
total uniformity.
You're happy with
your corner coffee shop.
They want to make you drink
Starbucks every day
from now until forever,
no matter how it tastes.
-"And when that hologram
drinks coffee,
what do you think happens?
Splashes right to the ground,
because holograms
don't have real stomachs."
Alright.
So, based on the clips,
they're not doing great.
Tucker Carlson thinks Joe Biden
is a hologram
who wants to make you
drink Starbucks every day.
And I'm sorry, but when is
the "Starbucks for liberals"
myth gonna die?
Are we supposed to believe
Tucker only drinks
campfire coffee
out of a prospector's tin mug?
And, by the way,
to anyone who thought
things were gonna go back
to normal once Trump is gone,
just a reminder -- Fox News
called Biden a hologram
who wants to force you
to drink Starbucks,
and he's been President-Elect
for two days.
Can you imagine
what it's gonna be like
when Biden's actually in office
if Republicans hang on
to control of the Senate?
Who knows if they'll even
let him have a Cabinet?
Sean Hannity will probably
accuse Biden of building
a secret Soros-funded
Amtrak station on the moon.
But you know what?
Say what you will
about Republicans --
one thing they make clear
is they're tough guys
who don't cry like liberals.
So, if anyone can handle
a bruising emotional defeat
like this one,
it's the Republican Party.
-This is one of the things --
just give people time.
-Yes.
-I mean, you know,
he's just found out
that he's probably not gonna be
the President
of the United States here.
And, I mean, you can say,
"Well, it was in the cards,"
but you don't know
until the votes are counted.
-I believe in decency
in all matters,
and I think
the decent thing to do
is let the President himself
take the time he wants
to absorb this.
It is not easy, and it is
extraordinarily close.
So if the President
needs to take a few days --
maybe even longer -- to absorb,
ultimately, accept --
and I think he ultimately will
accept the outcome
of the people --
you have to
allow that to happen.
-Truly incredible.
The "liberal tears" crowd --
the people who spent four years
building an entire
political movement
around triggering
their political opponents
need a warm blanket
and a cup of Earl Grey tea
to cope with losing
a presidential election.
They literally wore shirts that
said "[Bleep] your feelings."
"Yes, [bleep] your feelings,
but my feelings?
You make love to my feelings."
But this isn't just a case of
hurt feelings or wounded egos.
This is the beating heart
of Trumpism --
the paranoid,
authoritarian belief
that your political opponents
are illegitimate.
And even though Trump himself
might be on his way out,
the deep rot
that the rise has exposed
within our political system
isn't going anywhere
anytime soon,
and we can't pretend otherwise.
It runs through the veins
of the Republican Party,
which is why Trump
was thoroughly
and overwhelmingly repudiated.
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
won the most votes
for any presidential
ticket ever
and by one of the largest
margins in recent history.
They're on pace to potentially
win over 300 electoral votes.
Meanwhile, Trump is the
only president in history
to be impeached,
lose the popular vote,
and be denied a second term.
He's gonna be the answer
to a trivia question
for the rest of his life.
"Oh, man, I know this one.
Guy used to --
His name was on buildings!
Aaagh! You know -- golf guy!
Aah!
I knew I shouldn't have gotten
stoned before trivia night."
Again, Trump is not unique.
For example, last night,
he retweeted a clip
from Fox News
in which Ken Starr,
the special prosecutor from
the Clinton impeachment,
suggested that counting votes
was itself illegal.
-To count every vote
may be a crime.
[ Laughs ] It may even be
a crime under federal law.
It's definitely a crime
under state law if that is --
and here's the key word --
illegal.
And that's why you see --
and it's shameful
that Vice President Biden's
people
and the Vice President himself
are saying "Count every vote"
and selling a lot of T-shirts.
-Okay, putting aside
everything else for a second,
you're mad that
they're selling T-shirts?
All Trump does is sell
and advertise
Trump-branded products.
The entire Trump campaign
is like the merch table
outside a concert.
They have hats, shirts,
cups, flags.
There's even an official
Trump/Pence pet leash,
which just seems
way too on-the-nose.
[ Imitating Mike Pence ]
"Mr. President, I would prefer
if we didn't have
the leash on the website."
[ Imitating Donald Trump ]
"Oh, you know, I hear you, Mike,
and I'm gonna take that
under consideration
right after you fetch
this [bleep] ball for me!"
[ Normal voice ]
But I appreciate Ken Starr
revealing the ideological core
of the Republican Party --
their fundamental belief that
counting every vote is a crime.
They believe the democratic
process is illegitimate.
That's why they're manufacturing
deranged fantasies
of systemic voter fraud
without evidence.
Even when pressed for evidence,
they can't provide any.
-I know this city has
a sad history of voter fraud.
After all, Joe Frazier
is still voting here.
Kind of hard since he died
five years ago,
but Joe continues to vote.
If I recall correctly,
Joe was a Republican,
so maybe I shouldn't complain,
but we should go see
if Joe is voting
Republican or Democrat now
from the grave.
In Philadelphia,
they keep the votes
of dead people secret.
-Anytime Rudy does
a press conference,
I half expect him to be trailed
by an IV stand
and a nurse holding
a little cup full of pills.
One of these days, he's gonna be
interrupted halfway through
by an orderly yelling,
"Rudy! There you are!
Free time is o--
It's lights-out at 8:00, Rudy!"
[ Imitating Rudy Giuliani ] "I'm
making some very good points!
Can I finish making my --
They're very good points!"
[ Normal voice ]
Gets crazier, though,
because that's the same press
conference where Rudy found out
the networks had all
called the race for Trump,
and this was his response.
-Who was it called by?
All the --
Oh, my goodness!
All the networks!
Wow!
-You know, Rudy doesn't think
it's official
until it's called
by the "Texaco Star Theater."
Sounds like he's on the phone
with Time Warner
customer service.
"Alright, sir, we have
several packages available.
Which channels would you like?"
-All the networks!
-[ Laughs ] But by far,
the best thing
about this press conference
was not what Rudy said,
but where he said it.
It brings us to the
absolutely top part of the week,
and, honestly, it was
almost as good as Trump losing.
You see, the way we found out
about this press conference
was when Trump tweeted
"Lawyers news conference,
Four Seasons,
Philadelphia, 11:00 A.M.,"
and then he deleted that tweet
and followed up with another,
that said,
"Big press conference today
in Philadelphia
at Four Seasons
Total Landscaping, 11:30 a.m."
So, everyone thought they were
holding a press conference
at the upscale
Four Seasons Hotel,
and it turned out
they were holding it
at a landscaping company called
Four Seasons Total Landscaping,
and the hotel itself announced
they had no connection
to either Trump
or the landscaping company.
It's like if Trump announced
he was holding a big rally
at the Lincoln Memorial,
deleted it, then announced
he was holding a big rally
at a Lincoln dealership.
So, how did this absolutely
incredible moment
in history happen?
The Trump team
was reportedly looking
for a friendly part of town
to hold the press conference,
where they wouldn't get
drowned out by Biden supporters.
But according to
The New York Times,
"Aides told the President
on Saturday morning
their intended location
for the news conference,
and he misunderstood, assuming
it was an upscale hotel."
But I think it was even dumber.
I think Trump said,
"Do it at the Four Seasons,"
and one of his
chucklehead henchmen
just glanced at the Philly
phonebook, saw "Four Seasons,"
dialed the number before he saw
"Total Landscaping,"
and they just rolled with it
because nobody
can admit a mistake
in that fake
macho basement cult.
It's just the best.
He thought he was getting
a fancy hotel,
and instead, he got
a landscaping company.
Something tells me
this isn't the first time
this has happened to Rudy.
if you've ever seen him
sleeping in a courtyard,
It's because he thought
he was booking a room
at Courtyard by Marriott.
[ Imitating Giuliani ] "These
benches are so comfortable!
When's the turnover service?
Plus, they have
all the networks!"
[ Normal voice ] And it just
keeps getting better
once you learn what else was
near the landscaping company.
Again, this is where
the President's lawyer
held an official
press conference
falsely alleging a scheme
of wide-scale voter fraud
in order to undermine
an election.
-Originally, the President
billed this press conference
as taking place
at the Four Seasons Hotel
in downtown Philadelphia,
but it actually ended up
being held
in the back of Four Seasons
Total Landscaping --
no relation to the hotel --
very far from the center
of Philadelphia,
next to
Fantasy Island Adult Books,
across from the Delaware Valley
Cremation Center.
-That's right --
they held a press conference
at a landscaping company
next to an adult bookstore
and a cremation center.
So it was one-stop shopping
for Rudy.
[ Imitating Rudy Giuliani ]
"This is great.
I can get my hedges trimmed,
pick up a porno mag,
and then get cremated.
I can't wait
to pick out my urn!"
[ Normal voice ] The only thing
missing from this scene
was a store called
"Metaphors 'R Us."
Such a fitting way
for the Trump presidency to end.
They tried to stage
a deranged press conference
to undermine our democracy,
and it ended in
a humiliating spectacle
brought on by
their own incompetence.
Five years ago,
this whole nightmare started
in a golden tower in Manhattan.
Now, it's ending
at a landscaping company
in Philadelphia.
And yet, Rudy is not an outlier.
Today, Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell
refused to accept the outcome
of the election, as well,
despite the clear results with
no evidence of fraud whatsoever.
The President and virtually
the entire Republican party
are engaged in an attempt
to delegitimize the election
and blow up our democracy.
Clearly, the deep rot
in our political system
and in the conservative movement
exposed by Trump's rise
is not going away anytime soon.
He is not unique,
and fixing that will require
bold, systemic change.
So we'll be watching
on this network and on...
-All the networks!
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Whistle blows ]
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit
the "Donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.